[Music]
so
[Music]
bye
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
good afternoon and thank you all for
joining today's briefing
to discuss updates on operation warp
speed
i'm michael pratt the chief
communications officer for operation
warp speed and i'll be helping to
moderate today's briefing
briefing today our hhs secretary alex
azar dr robert redf
redfield the director for the centers
for disease control and prevention
dr monsev slowly chief scientific
advisor to operation warp speed
and general gus perna chief operating
officer for operation warp speed
they will all make opening statements
and after which we will open
the floor for on topic questions all
statements or answers today will be on
the record
and we kindly ask that you keep your
questions related to today's topic
when asking a question please do state
your name and publication and keep your
questions as short as possible so we can
get to as many as we can in the time we
have
any additional questions can be sent to
media hhs.gov
i'll now invite today's briefers to come
to the stage and we will begin
so
hello everyone and thank you for joining
this
week's operation warp speed briefing
i want to begin by providing some
context on how far we've come
and how that informs the next stage of
the vaccination program we're announcing
today
through operation warp speed we've
supported the development of six
candidate vaccines two have been shown
to be safe and
incredibly effective within record time
leading to the their authorization by
fda just last month
we've seen substantial rises in
americans
confidence in these vaccines and
interest in taking them
we are now at an important juncture in
the vaccine program
where we're ready for a transition that
we
outlined last september in the vaccine
playbook we sent to states
that shift occurs as supply expands to
meet demand
allowing us to expand the scope of
people recommended to receive the
vaccine
and expand the delivery sites used
we have achieved several milestones
several triggers
that brought us to this point nearly
38 million total doses of vaccine to
date
including about 25 million first doses
have been made available for states to
order against
with more becoming available this week
the doses allocated exceeds the priority
populations
in group 1a including frontline health
workers
and seniors living in long-term care
facilities
which means that supply now exceeds
demand from those groups
only four weeks into our launch we have
gained
confidence in the integrity of our
distribution system
which is now successfully delivered to
over fourteen thousand
locations essentially without a hitch
over the last several days we've
averaged around
seven hundred thousand reported
vaccinations
each day and we are on track to hit 1
million
per day in a week to 10 days time
in total we have more than 9 million
first vaccinations already given
far more than any western country by the
end of next week
95 percent of long-term care facilities
will have had their first
visit with vaccine doses
all of this means it's time to move on
to the next
phase of the vaccination campaign
as we had planned to do when the data
showed
we could this next phase
reflects the urgency of the situation we
face
every vaccine dose that is sitting in a
warehouse rather than going into an
arm could mean one more life lost or one
more hospital bed occupied
the next phase has several components
first we're expanding the groups getting
vaccinated
because state restrictions on
eligibility have obstructed
speed and accessibility of
administration
second we're telling states to expand
the channels and access points for
administering vaccines
and we're helping them to do so third
we are releasing the entire supply we
have for order by states
rather than holding second doses in
physical
reserve fourth
we are announcing a forthcoming change
to how we allocate doses in order to
encourage states to support rapid
vaccination
and to focus on the most vulnerable
so the first point about expanded
eligibility
we are telling states today that they
should open vaccinations to all of their
most
vulnerable people that is the most
effective way to save lives now
and some states heavy-handed
micromanagement of this process has
stood in the way of vaccines reaching a
broader swath of the vulnerable
population more quickly
specifically as dr redfield will discuss
we are telling states they should open
vaccinations to all
people over age 60 65 and over
and all people under age 65
with a comorbidity with some form of
medical documentation as defined
by governors leaders in some states have
forged ahead with steps like this
in very diverse settings and
demonstrated real
success i'll just mention a couple like
governor lamont in connecticut and
governor justice in west virginia
expanding eligibility to all of the
vulnerable is the fastest way to protect
the vulnerable
it's simply much easier to manage
allocating vaccines and appointments to
everyone 65 and over
rather than narrower more complex
categories and it enables states to use
much more diverse administration
channels
there was never a reason that states
needed to complete vaccinating all
health care providers before opening
vaccinations to
older americans and other vulnerable
populations
states should not be waiting to complete
1a
priorities before proceeding to broader
categories of eligibility
think of it like boarding an airplane
you might have a sequential order in
which
you board people but you don't wait
until literally
every person from a group is boarded
before moving on to the next
you have to keep the process moving
imagine if you find a gate agents for
boarding people out of order
you'd be standing at the gate for hours
of course moving on from an initial
phase of say healthcare workers before
everyone is vaccinated
is not declaring victory for that
category states should continue working
to support vaccinations of those
populations
but moving on to broader populations
when supply meets demand was always part
of the recommendations
cdc had provided to states second
we are telling states to open up more
channels for administration
and we're helping them do so hospital
debate hospitals made sense as the early
distribution sites when
the focus was on health care workers but
they are not where most americans go to
get vaccines
states should move on to pharmacies
community health centers and mass
vaccination sites
as desired or needed to support that
work last week we announced that states
could start using pharmacies enrolled
through our federal partnership with
19 pharmacy chains and associations
general purna dr redfield and some
pharmacy leaders
held a briefing for governors on this
topic last thursday
this federal partnership allows states
to allocate vaccines directly to these
partners
and these partners can then administer
vaccines to particular groups and
eventually to the general public these
pharmacy partners handle the
administrative tasks such as scheduling
appointments and reporting
vaccinations states can and should
choose the most strategically placed
pharmacy partners to send vaccines to
now
we're also activating our federally
qualified community health centers for
vaccination
some of these community health centers
are already being utilized by state
plans
but every state should be using them
community health centers have
more than thirteen thousand delivery
sites across america
and they have both particularly
convenient locations
and strong connections in low income and
minority communities
further if states wish to set up mass
vaccination sites
we stand ready to help both through cdc
guidance and
other support including deploying
personnel to assist with technical
expertise and setup
we're here to work with them states have
ample funding
including three billion dollars more on
the way
to support such efforts third
we're now making the full reserve of
doses we have available for order
we are 100 committed to ensuring a
second
dose is available for every american who
receives a first dose let me repeat that
our approach continues to ensure
that there will be a second dose
available for someone who gets a first
dose of vaccine
based on the science and evidence we
have it is imperative
that people receive their second doses
on time
that's what the science says and
ignoring that would be reckless
but we'd always plan to move to a more
advanced
phase of how we manage this once we had
confidence in our supply chains
that is the key trigger we needed to see
because we now have a consistent pace of
production
we can now ship all of the doses that
had been held in physical reserve
with second doses being supplied by
doses coming
off of manufacturing lines with quality
control going forward
each week doses available would be
released
to first cover the needed second doses
and then
cover additional first vaccinations
finally effective two weeks from now
we are changing how we allocate first
doses
among the states in order to ensure
doses are being put to use
and put to use for the most vulnerable
we will be allocating them based on the
pace of administration
as reported by states and by the size
of the 65 and over population
in each state we're giving states two
weeks notice of this shift to give them
the time necessary to plan and to
improve their reporting
if they think their data is faulty
this new system gives states a strong
incentive to ensure that all
vaccinations are being promptly reported
which they're currently not and it gives
states a strong incentive to ensure
doses are going to work to go into work
protecting people
rather than sitting on shelves or in
freezers
with the case counts we face now there
is absolutely no time to waste
we need doses going to where they'll be
administered quickly
and where they'll protect the most
vulnerable
finally as we face rising case counts in
a number of parts of the country
we need all americans to keep up the
same public health measures
we've been recommending throughout this
crisis hope is here in the form of
vaccines we
just have to keep up our guard for a bit
longer
i want to add one more key message to
our recommendations of washing your
hands watching your distance and wearing
your face coverings when you can't watch
your distance
if you test positive and are at risk for
severe disease
meaning you are over 65 or have a
comorbidity
you should be asking your doctor or
health care provider
why you are not being given one of the
fda
authorized antibody therapies that are
in ready supply
we have products sitting on the shelves
that can help keep
people out of the hospital that is just
as unacceptable as vaccines
sitting on shelves unused people in the
appropriate categories
should be asking their doctors or health
care providers why they aren't
being offered these antibody therapies
with that i'll hand things over to
dr redfield our cdc director dr
reckfield
thank you mr secretary uh i want to echo
some of the important comments that the
secretary made
um clearly as we began vaccination
with our front line healthcare workers
and individuals in long-term
nursing care and assisted living
that was the initial phase to begin to
roll out this vaccine distribution
as the secretary said that as we sit
here
in the fourth week of this vaccination
program
we now are at a time where actually
there's more vaccine available
than is being requested for vaccination
within the 1a group
the acip and cdc guidelines that came
out
on vaccination to the states were never
meant to be
somehow finished the first phase then
you move to the second phase then you
move to the third
so i'm here as a cdc director to ask
our governors to echo what the secretary
said and strongly
recommend the vaccination now be
expanded to those individuals
65 are over and those individuals
between 16 or 18 depending on the
vaccine being used
to 64 that have a comorbidity with a
medical documentation
of such we clearly have enough vaccine
at this point to begin to expand and get
more and more of the vulnerable
individuals
in our country vaccinated this is
particularly important right now
as we're seeing the post-holiday surge
surge we have many jurisdictions now
that
are on the verge of going from a
linear growth to basically exponential
growth
and we believe it's critically important
at this time
to get those most vulnerable people as
quickly as we can
into vaccination programs as a key
strategy
to maintain hospital resilience i also
want to echo what the secretary
said about the importance of using the
approved
eua approved monoclonal antibodies for
individuals at highest risk that develop
symptoms prior to hospitalization that's
a second really important uh
intervention that we have at this moment
to maintain hospital resilience
and finally i just have to echo also
the closing comments of the secretary
this is a time that we call on all
americans
to be vigilant in the mitigation steps
that we've asked particularly
in their own house households most of
transmission that is occurring in our
nation right now is not occurring in the
public square
it's occurring one household to one
household to one household
so again wear a mask they work
social distance it works of staying away
and being smart about crowds
washing your hands they work
we need to work all together now it's
going to be a difficult
difficult january and probably february
but with a vaccine and the new
therapeutics we have
there's really strong light at that end
of that tunnel as we enter march
but we need to really commit right now
and get as many americans vaccinated as
we can that are particularly the most
vulnerable and at risk for
hospitalization
thank you we'll have general kerner next
month yeah general kerner we'll talk
next
good morning everybody so uh we
are in the beginning of uh or continuing
our new fa
our execution right and i'm very excited
i'm very proud about it
a month ago is when we started
delivering vaccines
uh around the world around the country
and it went to the hospitals as we
focused on the categories for
first line medical responders four weeks
later we've made significant progress
as the secretary has highlighted and
there is nobody working
harder right to ensure that vaccines are
being distributed
than the ows team uh in execution
to get it to where it needs to be so
distribution of the vaccines is getting
them to the states so that they can
ensure that it gets to the arms and we
are enabling that every day
we as the secretary said have sent over
25 million doses of vaccines
over to 16 000 different locations
really really great effort the cadence
of allocations the cadence of orders
the cadence of picking and packing the
cadence of what's being shipped
has really become a remarkable feat for
all of us right the whole of america to
be proud of
we are executing this uh every day
every week and the months will go by
and the result the effects will be safe
and effective vaccine to the american
people
i do want to as i always do thank the
men and women
of pfizer moderna mckesson fedex
and ups who are working 24 hours a day
seven days a week to deliver the vaccine
in a timely manner as the secretary
talked about
our responsibility is to make sure all
vaccine
that is uh releasable available for
distribution gets out to the american
people and that is what we are doing
as early as 24 november standing right
here talking to you
i talked about our ability to plan
our ability to collaborate our ability
to see ourselves
and then to make sure we continue to
execute to the maximum extent possible
delivering the most vaccines to the
american people
that is what we're doing now that is
what the secretary
laid out in execution of how we are
managing
the second doses to ensure first and
foremost it's always available
but second we ensure that the max
available doses of vaccine
are available to the american people
every day
are my personal confidence
in both the distribution capability as
demonstrated over the last four weeks
as and the addition of manufacturing
confidence
has increased significantly which allows
me to approach
and execute distribution and allocation
of the vaccines
differently it ensures maximum execution
and allows us to pass maximum doses of
vaccine
to the american people in a timely
manner
today i want to give you a quick update
of where we are with the facilities
uh that we've made significant progress
in working to get long-term health care
facilities
uh up and running in collaboration with
cvs and walgreens
we know we have 70 000 facilities that
are enrolled
which includes uh skilled nursing
facilities and assisted living
facilities
we started in week one right three weeks
ago with 900 facilities
in three weeks since we've completed
over 11
000 facilities all just under a million
first doses have been given
12 000 more clinics are scheduled this
week
and every week following as we go
forward
today we know that we are making a
difference
in these facilities and it is because of
the great work by the cdc
cvs and walgreens that are making the
difference
as the secretary said we are quickly
coming on
to administering first dose to everybody
in these in this category we are
expanding our distribution to the retail
pharmacies as the secretary talked about
we have opened it up for states to
utilize the over 40
000 provider pharmacy providers that are
enrolled
and we want to expand it up to 70 000
providers that are enrolled we think
that
we can open up the aperture and give
access
greater access to the american people
through the pharmacies
what does it do it allows uh us to have
confidence in the executors it allows us
to distribute it throughout the country
it allows us to give a place where the
american people are comfortable
of going and receiving the shot i want
to give you four
slides that i asked the team to put
together the first slide is the
vaccinations
that we executed on day one of
distribution of the fisa product
right we went to over 636
sites on day one across the country of
our country why did we do this
specifically it was the pfizer vaccine
we knew there was cold chain
requirements we wanted to ensure
capability and capacity uh match the
distribution
we worked with states we collaborated
with them and we put it exactly where
they wanted it when they wanted it
on the second week when we brought the
moderna vaccine in
we were able to expand distribution
primarily because of the availability of
doses at
lower amounts where the maduro vaccine
is at a hundred minimum ordering at a
hundred doses
so what could we do we could expand out
through the country
because of the dose requirement minimum
dose requirement
and also less refrigeration requirement
we were able to
send doses to long-term health care
facilities we were able to extend it
into doctor's offices and into
pharmacies
as the states asked us to do so the
expansion was quick and rapid
in just a week now today as of yesterday
we have gone to over 16 000 locations
across the country
right as depicted on this slide we go
there on a routine basis delivering
vaccines
as directed by the states in
distribution to the quantities and
locations
that they want really covering the mass
population
of the country now what is in the realm
of possible
this last slide as we open up the 70
000 pharmacy chain and individual
capabilities
we are covering the entire united states
and vaccine can be distributed as of
this week
to where the states would like it to go
across the country
we know that these pharmacies because
we've been working with them at the cdc
level
are ready to execute this mission and as
the states
allocate vaccine to them and direct it
we are ready to deliver to all these
locations
every day every week every month
as required this alone will open up the
capability
and capacity to ensure that the american
people have direct
access to the vaccine as we go forward
so in closing uh challenging times
as i've told you many times and the
secretary
said we we are not fighting the plan
right we are fighting the situation and
we are making adjustments
uh and moving forward in that light just
like we had always planned to do
uh we are just able to uh
change in a more rapid and steady pace
i want to say thank you for all the
support
uh from uh the states i want to say
thank you for again to the industry
partners
that are helping us execute this
flawless
distribution uh because every day they
do their job
more vaccine gets out to the american
people uh and then in closing
uh as i like to remind us all there is a
group of people that are on the front
lines every single day
uh helping us take care of those uh
uh who who have reached a certain point
of their illness
and these medical professionals and
their supported staff
are really just doing a tremendous job
and i just want to say thanks to all of
you
so that concludes my comments mr
secretary
thank you very much and uh i did want to
note as you saw
dr slowly is with us on stage and will
be available for questions he just
didn't feel the need to have an opening
opening statement but uh michael pratt
thank you all we will now open up for
questions operator a friendly reminder
that when asking a
question please state your name in
publication and please keep your
questions
as short as possible so we can get to as
many as we can
in the time that we have and i'll turn
it over to the operator
thank you so very much if you would like
to ask a question please press star then
one on your phone
and be sure to provide your name and
media outlet our first now is from
drew armstrong with bloomberg news
sir your line is open hi it's uh
drew i run our vaccine tracker here and
had a question for you all
about what has actually been the problem
in administering shots in some of these
states that are
showing low numbers of percentage of the
distributions to them
used because clearly there's a number of
states that are working through between
70 and 80
of their distributions on a rolling
basis
but others you know mississippi alabama
georgia
north carolina perpetually kind of stuck
in
a very low percentage of what's been
shipped to them
is it that it got distributed to the
wrong places are they having problems
with are there holdups in shipping what
what is actually going on here because i
don't think we've really gotten a good
answer from
anybody about where these bottlenecks
are that are preventing some states from
reaching some of the numbers that you
all have cited as being successes
elsewhere
yeah drew and i'll ask general pernit or
dr redfield to add to add to what i've
got to say but
first we need to recognize that
we're now four weeks into this program
and this is a major operational
logistics issue it's a scale-up as with
any enterprise you're going to have a
scale
up that is predictable and known that
that would happen
but we have seen variable performance
among the states and among providers
what's going on there now each state may
be slightly different but for the most
part what we have seen
is the states that are lagging it's
certainly could be a data issue
the health commissioner here in the
district of columbia for instance
revealed that
40 of pharmacies aren't reporting we had
data reporting issues with one chain
pharmacy in terms of its ability to
connect into the system on vaccinations
we had one state that has had some
significant challenge with
interconnectivity of data reporting
systems and
as dr redfield can let you know what
we're asking for is very novel
in the history of vaccination programs
in the united states usually
with public health vaccinations our
providers have to report within 30 days
right bob
yes sir within 30 days now they've
they've signed as part of their
agreement to be providers
in tiberius with operation warp speed
agreements to provide their data within
72 hours but
that's a major workflow change for them
and uh there are going to be kinks in
the system on that data
uh improving consistently over time and
i think with the new incentives that we
are announcing today that states will
receive their allocations in part based
on the data that we have on
what percent of vaccines they've
received have they actually
gotten administered we'll see that data
improve
the other major barrier and i talked
about this last week
has been states that are being overly
prescriptive and trying to micromanage
every single dose of vaccine down to who
gets it
to ensure that only group 1a people
get vaccinated before they're willing to
open up and look at group 1b people even
if that's the approach that they're
taking
so that might be states that
are insisting that all healthcare
providers have to be vaccinated before
you start vaccinating the most
vulnerable
that's why from the get-go i've talked
about the need to not be
cabined in by the different groups from
the acip
or from the cdc they're not meant to be
prescriptive
some governors have overreacted have
taken them in overly prescriptive manner
and
this is a logistical issue this is an
operational issue
if you try to be too micromanaged too
tailored
too focused you let the perfect be the
enemy of the good in a mass vaccine
campaign like this
i said last week we would rather have
some low price
lower priority individuals get
vaccinated along with the high priority
individuals
if it makes us go fast and if it avoids
vaccines sitting on the shelves and
and for the love of god not having
vaccine
actually wasted or thrown away because
of a failure to administer
um so those have been the major issues
really at the state level it's first
reporting
overly prescriptive approaches to
vaccination and an unwell and then
finally an unwillingness to
to move to alternative channels of
distribution over alliance i call it the
hospitalization of vaccine distribution
and that was natural as i said
at the outset but it's time to move
beyond that we have too much vaccine
sitting in freezers at hospitals with
hospitals not using it now sometimes
hospital systems can be very effective
partners in these vaccine programs
as they have networks they have primary
care practices they are themselves
health systems not just hospitals and so
if they can
get to their patients get to their
customers and clients that are
vulnerable those 65 and above and those
under age 6 64 and below who have
co-morbidities
uh well that's ideal also but use every
channel get the vaccine out there
i would rather have people have people
working to get appointments to get
vaccinated
than having vaccine going to waste
sitting in freezers general perna or dr
redfield anything you'd like to add
thank you mr secretary and i agree with
your answers
the other thing i would just say is
right now cdc is doing a
i'll call a deep dive on the 64
jurisdictions
to try to understand exactly what that
issue is i do think a lot of it is
reporting
as the secretary said the standard that
cdc has had
in the past for reporting vaccination
was to providers to report within 30
days
we're now asking them to report within
three days so i do think some of that is
part of the hiccup but
we're doing a deep dive in all the
jurisdictions as was mentioned some of
them are less than 15 percent
and then we have other jurisdictions
that are over 80 percent to understand
exactly what those factors are and
i'm pretty confident we'll have an
understanding of that by the end of the
week
general did you have anything mr
secretary i agree with all that was just
said
uh completely i would just add the
separation of distribution
from actual administration uh we are
tracking distribution
at a success rate of 99.999 percent
uh so in other words as long if the
state tells us where they want it in one
of the 70
000 enrolled providers we are able to
distribute their
uh in accordance with the order uh and
we
uh we pfizer moderna mckesson
ups and fedex are literally going
through snowstorms
uh and distributing vaccine every day
uh to the to the location as desired
at a very high success rate
next question that is from dan
vergano with buzzfeed news your line is
open
thank you dan vergano buzzfeed news i'm
wondering if this change will
necessitate any widening of the time
window for the 21-day and 28-day second
dose
what what is the widening how close to
21 or 28 days you have to get now
who's advisory committee has said you
might go to six weeks
what do you see as the window for that
or what do you recommend
so dan thank you for asking about that i
want to be very clear the labeled
indication from the fda on the vaccines
for the pfizer vaccine is 21 days
between first dose and second dose and
28 days
between first dose and second dose for
the moderate vaccine
that's what the clinical trials were
based on that is the data submitted to
the fda
and that is what we are executing
towards so that is the goal now if
people end up coming in a day or so on
each side
the goal is still 21 or 28 days but we
are not comfortable with approaches that
are not based in
evidence that has been generated to
support these incredibly safe and
effective vaccines and i think that's
part of why
the american public has seen has shown
such surging vaccine confidence that
every aspect of this has been data and
science driven
and the fda will make the determinations
what appropriate administrations are
the general laid out and this was always
part of the plan
you can go back to my statements i think
it was in december at these press
conferences where i said
what we're going to do is manage the
flow of vaccines
we must ensure that if you get a first
vaccine
there will be a second vaccine at the 21
day or the 28 day mark at the provider
for you to get that
we have two sources for vaccine one
would be holding back some of the
initial stocks of vaccine that were that
were releasable
in december to guarantee that we'd have
that second dose
but i said over time as we gain
confidence in the manufacturing quality
and processes of moderna and pfizer
and with our deep deep deep operation
warp speed engagement at moderna
and our increasing engagement now with
pfizer and their manufacturing processes
and use of the defense production act
we have greater visibility and greater
confidence in their production
capabilities
we now have been able to move to where
we do not need to hold back reserve
doses
because we can predict with better
certainty the doses that will arrive
off the production lines and quality
control at the 21 day and 28 day mark to
fulfill our second dose
obligations to patients and that will be
our primary
and so if their heaven forbid
were any type of glitches in production
the way this would work is
new production off the production lines
would be going towards
first and foremost fulfilling the second
dose obligation
and any first doses would be delayed to
ensure that patients get at the 21 or 28
day mark
that second dose thank you we have time
for two more questions
thank you our next from ricardo alonso
associated press your line is now open
hi thank you for taking my question and
mr secretary can you walk us through
the change in allocation to the states
that you announced today
does that mean that some states may end
up
getting less than they otherwise would
have
and is there a risk of disruption with
that and finally
do you have buy-in to that approach from
the
uh incoming administration so ricardo
thank you for the question on that
uh so the two changes that we have
outlined are
first that that are allocations among
the states
will not remain purely on a per capita
basis
but rather be based on the reported data
showing the percentages of vaccine
administered
versus their allocations that they've
received in other words
if you're not using vaccine that you
have the right to
then we should be rebalancing to states
that are
using that vaccine it is common sense
it it it seems hard to actually defy
that but we want to give notice
especially because of these data issues
uh we want to give notice within two
weeks we'll be doing that
so get your data in order work on that
data for ricardo you may remember we
followed a very similar approach
when we were in shortage situations with
remdesavir
doing allocations to the states uh and
needing to get reported data on
remdessevere location
and utilization uh and so we followed
that approach and it worked
exceptionally well
in the context of room design and then
the other change is to really emphasize
to make it very clear how vitally
important it is
to prioritize and focus on those who are
most vulnerable for whom the vaccine
will have the biggest effect and those
are those age 65 and over
and those 64 and below with
comorbidities and so
that will be a change i believe it's
about 10 states most impacted based on
the data
there it'd be fairly common sense where
that would be
but again our states aren't using 100 of
their allocated vaccine
so this ends up being i think at least
in the interim of redistribution
between and among the states that should
not necessarily
hurt many states but will enhance the
benefit
to those that are actually getting
vaccines done and performed
thanks next question please time for one
last question
our final question is from tom howell
with the washington
times and your line is now open
hi thanks for doing the call um can you
address the back end of ricardo's
question about whether the biden team
has bought into that plan
and also can dr schlowi update us on
astrazeneca
and j j when will they seek approval and
how many doses have you secured
of either one thanks so uh we at the
operation warp speed board
uh made the determination on the changes
and read
and distribution allocation
methodologies among the states
uh while we will certainly brief the
biden team
on those changes uh we operate as you
know with one government at a time
and we this is the approach that we
believe
best fulfills the mission and the
current situation
uh that we are facing thank you
dr thank you for your question
uh so regarding the janssen's vaccine
as you know the phase 3 trial is fully
recruited there are
unfortunately fortunately for the trial
very significant number of cases
accruing
uh we are very clear we meaning
operation and jansen's pharmaceuticals
that analysis will be completed before
the end of the month
and the eua submission will take place
at the end of this month in terms of
vaccine those
availability if submission is happening
at the end of
january one could project that
approval of the emergency use
authorization may happen
somewhere in the middle of the month of
february we project to have single digit
million
number of doses available in the second
half of february
we're trying to make that number get as
close
to a double-digit number as possible and
then
a larger number in march and a much
larger number
in uh april remember this is a one-shot
vaccine
so those are millions of individuals
fully immunized
in terms of the astrozonica vaccine the
assumption we are working on
is that the emergency use authorization
will be submitted on the basis of the
ongoing phase free trial in the us
the phase free trial is effectively
fully enrolled there are a few
individuals
more enrolled on a primarily to
[Music]
ensure appropriate representation of all
diverse population
in in the country cases are accruing
the uh 60 days upon
completion of full immunization schedule
follow-up safety as required by the fda
guidance
happens during the first week of the
month of march
and the projection would be to have a
submission of the eua around that time
assuming of course that cases have
accrued again unfortunately i think that
will be the case
and uh hopefully the vaccine again is
efficacious
as has been shown in the trials
conducted in
brazil and in the uk so
maybe an approval somewhere towards the
latter part of the month of march and a
significant number of doses
available around that time and since you
asked the question maybe i'll
also update on the novovax vaccine the
novavax vaccine is the fifth
program out of the six programs we have
that
is in phase three trial or completed the
phase three trial
the face free trial has now recruited
about uh
8 000 or so subjects is recruiting very
fast at a rate of 800
very early in the month of february and
based on timelines of immunization etc
may be there we can have an outcome
somewhere in the month
of uh very late march or in april
the sanofi trial program which is the
last program in our portfolio
will start phase 2b trial in the middle
of february in a comparative trial to a
messenger rna
vaccine maybe also on a progress part of
things we are working
now experimentally testing sierra for
identification of immune correlates of
protection that's really super important
because
if and when we have the data somewhere
in the middle of february is the
projection currently
that's identifying immunocorrects of
protection
that will dramatically accelerate
potential approval of other vaccines
including the protein vaccines
particularly that from sanofi and
vaccines from others
and of course across the world provided
people use
readouts that are validated or
cross-validated with the readouts that
have been used i do want to say find the
final point
is we are running a clinical trial a
phase three trial in
adolescence 12 to 18 years of all of age
with the modern vaccine uh
it's a real challenge it's been four
weeks ongoing we only recruited about
800 subjects in the trial
remember i just said earlier the
asterisk the sorry novavax vaccine is
recruiting 800 subjects per day
here we're talking about 800 subjects in
a month
it's really very important for all of us
for all the population in america to
realize that we can't have that
indication
unless adolescents age 12 to 18
decide to participate of course as a
voluntary decision
into the clinical trials we need to
recruit about 3000 subjects into the
trial to complete them
thank you
so this is very likely
the last operation warp speed briefing
with this team
for you all i just wanted to express
three notes of thanks first i want to
thank the members of the media who
participated in these operation warp
speed calls
uh you have been unfailingly
professional
and allowed an educational and technical
level briefing uh that i hope your
readers and listeners and viewers
uh have appreciated we have tried it
every step of the way to be factual and
transparent with you and
bring you on the journey with us of
vaccine approvals and
distribution and now administration so
thank you for
making that possible second i want to
express my appreciation to secretary
former secretary esper acting secretary
miller and deputy secretary norquist of
the defense department
the collaboration between dod and hhs
has been
unprecedented uh and really in my
uh in my decades around government uh
government service
i've just never seen this type of
collaboration in cooperation that's
really that comes from the top
that is a credit to the leadership of
the defense department to make this
happen
so thank you for that finally
people is policy and
we fortunately at the outset of
operation warp speed we're able to have
some exceptional people leading this uh
in all of my time leading in business
and in government
i have never been part of a team that
has
that has ex has demonstrated teamwork
and professionalism and integrity
discipline as this team does and
uh i want to express my personal
appreciation to
all of the members of the team but
especially
uh general purna who was a hero for
america
before he did this now he's a hero for
america's public health
to monsef slowly who is a hero of the
biopharmaceutical industry
before doing this and is now a hero of
america's public health
these selfless individuals have
dedicated every waking minute
since they were tapped back in may to
lead these efforts
the results have been remarkable and i
i hope that uh the next team with the
biden administration will be able to
carry forward these results we will do
everything in our power
to ensure a smooth and effective
continued transition
the first meeting i believe of any
transition team
between this administration the biden
administration was before thanksgiving
and it was for operation warp speed
and we'll continue those efforts uh up
through the last day of this
administration into the by and into the
biden administration
so thank you all very much we appreciate
everything
thank you mr secretary uh additional
follow-up questions can be sent to media
hhs.gov and i'll turn it over to the
operator to finish up the call thank you
conference is now concluded again thank
you everyone for your participation
please go ahead and disconnect
thank you very much
[Music]
you